[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
a boy duncan can i trust you something
yes always you know that i've been
having dreams
about a girl on maracas i don't know
what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house of tradies there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling the emperor
asks us to bring peace to arrakis house
atreides
accepts
[Music]
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready you've never met
harkins before they're not human they're
brutal
the duke's son sees too much
is why you kill them all
god in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
dad what if i'm not the future of house
of treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead he's
called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
[Applause]
it's time
your gamers
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dreamed them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learned
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
[Applause]
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
his own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
my lord duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go
[Music]
you